DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
So the problem that I
want to work with you
now is to compute
some integrals,
but we want to compute them
in the presence of a density
function.
So the region that we're
considering is very simple.
It's just the unit square.
So we have the origin here,
we have the line x equals 1,
we have the line y
equals 1, and we just
want to compute in this region.
And so we want to use
this density function
to find various sort of physical
characteristics of this region.
So first, we want
to find its mass,
and so we are going
to need to recall
how you get mass from density.
We want to find
the center of mass.
That is, where is the point
on which we could balance this
if we cut it out?
If we tried to balance
it on our fingers,
where is the average
mass concentrated?
We want to find the moment
of inertia about the origin,
and we want to find the moment
of inertia about the x-axis.
So we're going to have
to remember our formulas
for moments of inertia.
So why don't you pause
the video and work
on this for a little bit.
Check back with me and I'll
show you how I solved it.
Hi.
Welcome back.
Why don't we start
by finding the mass.
So the mass is the most
straightforward of these,
and I find it helpful to use
the language of differentials.
So what I want us
to do is I want
us to take a little square
here, and this little square
has area dA.
OK?
And what we want
to do is we want
to sum up the masses of all
the little squares dA here.
So what we want to know is what
is the little bit of mass dM
which corresponds to this
little bit of area dA.
And more or less by
definition, this is delta dA.
So delta is the ratio
of area to mass.
And so this little
contribution of mass
is just delta times the
little contribution of area.
OK?
Now, once we write
it this way, then
our total mass for
the entire square
is just the integral
over the region of all
the little contributions of dM.
And so in particular, this
is just the integral from x
equals 0 to 1, y equals 0 to 1.
We have x*y--
that's our density--
and then we have dy dx.
OK.
And this is an integral
which we can just compute.
So why don't we compute
this one all the way through
and see what we get.
OK.
So we have integral
x equals 0 to 1.
So we have x*y, and we need
to integrate that in y.
So we have x y squared over 2.
And then y ranges
from 1 to 0, dx.
So this is the integral from x
equals 0 to 1 of x over 2, dx.
And this is just x squared
over 4 from 1 to 0.
This is just 1/4.
So that tells us that the
total mass of this unit square
is 1/4.
OK.
So now, we need
to do similar-- we
have a similar challenge for
the other physical quantities.
We just need to figure out what
is the appropriate differential
quantity, and then we just
need to integrate that.
For b, we need to compute
the center of mass.
So remember that
the center of mass
involves finding the
average x-coordinate
and the average y-coordinate.
And I wanted to remind
you what the formula is
for the center of
mass, and remind you
how I remind myself of it.
So in the formula for
the center of mass,
we need to take the
average of x times dM
divided by the integral of dM.
So this is our formula
for the center of mass.
And I just wanted
to say that the way
that I remember this is
by thinking about seesaws.
So if you think about
it-- and if we were not
doing multiple variables
but a single variable--
if I had a seesaw, and
I had some weights.
So I had m_1 and m_2 and m_3
and m_4-- I had some weights--
and these were at positions
x_1 and x_2 and x_3 and x_4.
Well, the fact that the
scale would be balanced
would be to say that this point
x here, where the fulcrum is
located, is exactly the weighted
average of these points.
That's what's going to
guarantee that there's
the same amount of torque
pushing this way and this way.
So if we were in one
variable and we just
had some discrete
weights, then we
would want to take the average
of all of these positions,
and we would want to
weight it with the masses.
So we would want to take the
sum of x_i*m_i and divide
by the sum of m_i.
This would be the
average coordinates
in this kind of toy example.
And now if you look at the
formula for the center of mass,
it's really the same
thing, isn't it?
Because integrals are just a
continuous version of the sum.
We have x as a function
instead of x_i as a list.
And the m_i's are just the
little infinitesimal dM's here.
And then the bottom here is just
the total mass of the system,
and so is this.
OK, so that's how I think about
this center of mass formula.
And it's actually
pretty easy to compute.
So we have the integral from x
equals 0 to 1, y equals 0 to 1.
So now we have x times
delta times dx dy.
So altogether we get
x squared y dy dx.
So one of those x's
is because we're
averaging x and the other one
is from the density function.
So we have this whole integral.
And then we divide by
this integral of the mass,
but we already computed
this in part a,
and we found it to be 1/4.
OK.
So this numerator here is fairly
straightforward to compute.
And if you do this
you'll get-- let
me double check-- I
believe we got 1/6.
So you should get 1/6 when
you compute this integral.
So we have 1/6 over 1/4, and
so cancelling off, this is 2/3.
OK.
So that was just the
x center of mass.
But now I want to make
an important point, which
is that this density function
is symmetric in x and y.
It was just x times y.
It wasn't something
more complicated.
And so the center of
mass in the x-direction
is just equal to the center
of mass in the y-direction,
so these are both equal to 2/3.
OK.
So that depended on the fact
that our density was symmetric,
and also on the fact
that our region was
symmetric about
switching x and y.
So we could save ourselves
some trouble here.
OK, very good.
So now to do c, again
we need to recall
what is the infinitesimal
moment of inertia.
So let me draw
this picture again.
So here's our little dA here.
And we want to know the
infinitesimal moment of inertia
around the origin.
So we tie a string to
this little piece of mass,
and we start spinning
it, and we want
to know what is our moment
of inertia corresponding
to that little mass.
And I'll just remind
you from lecture
that the formula
is r squared dM.
So this is r squared
times x*y dx dy.
And so the r squared
here is saying
that as you get farther
and farther out,
your moment of inertia is
getting larger and larger.
And this makes sense in
terms of the physical idea
that you're moving a longer
distance if you're farther out.
So anyway.
So this is our
formula, r squared dM.
And so that tells us that I
is just the integral of dI.
And so this is the integral
from x goes from 0 to 1,
y goes from 0 to 1.
And then we have x
squared plus y squared--
that's just r squared--
times x*y dx dy.
And so we can rewrite this as
x cubed y plus x y cubed dx dy.
And this is a computation
that we can do.
Let me just check
my notes real quick.
So this is 1/4.
I'll skip the computation,
but this is just
integrating some polynomials,
so we can do that.
All right.
And now finally, we want to
compute the moment of inertia--
so remember, d asked us to
compute the moment of inertia
around the x-axis.
So instead of around the
origin, it's around the x-axis.
So the idea here is the same.
So again, dI is a
factor times dM.
And again, it's the
radius, but now it's
the radius about
which we're spinning.
So we're not anymore
spinning around the origin
as we were doing before.
Now we're spinning
around-- sort of out
of the board-- around
the x-axis here.
But we still have
the same formula,
and now our radius
is the height y.
Because we're not spinning
around the origin anymore,
we're spinning
around this rod here.
And so if you think
about it, that's
the radius about which we're
spinning is just the height y.
So this is just y squared delta.
OK.
And so that tells us that
I-- the total inertia
about the x-axis-- is
just the integral of dI.
And so we get the integral
from x equals 0 to 1,
integral y equals 0 to 1.
And then we just have
y squared x*y dy dx.
And this, again, we
could compute-- and let
me just check my notes--
and find that it's 1/8.
So in each of these problems,
the most important thing
to have been able
to do is to argue,
what is this sort of
infinitesimal contribution
to the physical quantity
that you want to compute?
And eventually, you
want to express it
in terms of the quantity dA,
because dA is what we actually
can integrate.
And so all the other
physical quantities
that we need to
study are going to be
an integral of some
infinitesimal element,
and that infinitesimal
element is
going to be some
coefficient times dA.
So here, we had that
this was-- oh, dear.
This is a mistake.
So this should have
said y squared dM,
and that's y squared delta dA.
So I wrote the delta implicitly.
I wrote it twice.
So what we meant to say is
dI is y squared delta dA.
And so in all these examples,
the infinitesimal quantity
that we're after is some
straightforward coefficient
times the infinitesimal area.
And so once we know
that, then we can just
do a straightforward integral.
OK, and I'll leave it at that.